you guys shot this in scotland is that
right oh yeah a little bit yup let's
just say yeah yeah no no no no i was
over there a little bit you guys
i understand you guys shot this in
scotland yeah we did
yeah we did how did the scottish people
receive you i've never been to scotland
i know nothing about it
it's a beautiful spot
the uh we stayed in castles
no hotels that looked like castles
and uh you did yeah
where were you staying it's just like an
old hotel
don't they all put you in the same place
no no no we're there at different times
um it's incredible it's pretty cold
but um
it's beautiful i don't know but that's
that's yeah
i wasn't really asking about the
temperature no uh
i wasn't there very long was it
why can we type that again yeah no no
we're good we're good anthony uh i
understand there was some uh almost
violence on this there was a lot of
violence
yeah because we were down by the like
the main bar strip
so there was one day we were on set and
this dude wanted to get to a bar on the
opposite side of set
so there was the little pa you know
poor pas you guys you do you do so much
for us and we thank you
god bless you
and this little pa was like no you can't
come across set and the dude was like
are you gonna let me across i think
that's more
but it's not a trigger that was good
you won't be stopping me from getting
over that that's irish that's iris
that's irish ah i must get through
it
um
you can take our lawn so he was like
i'm going to get roussette
oh my gosh that was good
he tries he jumps and he decks this
police officer what what yeah real rap
and runs across set runs across the
train station goes to the pub and gets
to the bar orders his drink and the
police come in they're like oh he's in
the pub like
oh if he's in a pub
okay we'll get them laid up and they
leak
i'm like sure this dude just knocked out
of police ordered a drink and they're
like well we can't disturb his beer
we'll get him later
avengers movie should be you guys
instead of you know thanos or some
creature that can't be defeated it
should be you just fighting scottish
people
awesome william
scottish drunk yes scottish drunk people
and it is like a tie
full on hulk is like
no migo oh no they ran back into the pub
we'll get them when they come back out
must respect time in pub
uh what's the uh temperature in the
morning temperature versus the evening
temperature in scotland oh wow so cold
in scotland um
good morning it's like two degrees
celsius really okay which fahrenheit
yeah if you've got any mathematicians
40. yeah yeah and then the evening is
something like three yeah that's like
45.
the winner or when is it it's such a
nice place
oh it's both it's
flat lines